these shoes that I discovered they're
like tiny little rain boots that doesn't
have a whole boot they just rubber shoes
I love gardening with them at first me
and my girlfriend both bought a pair and
also we wear the same shoe size so we're
very blessed that we can just
interchange our shoes yeah these are
beautiful look at the color it's by this
brand called CVS we just saw it at a
store in Santa Barbara when we're like
in the midst of wine tasting so this was
definitely like a drunken purchase but
it has been the best pair of shoes so
far it's better than any slides it's
like a real pair of shoes it's
comfortable with driving good for the
rain and started what as gardening shoes
and now I just wear it everywhere even
for a GQ interview
[Music]